so his lawyer was on Pierce Morgan we're
going to talk about that but let's talk
about the incel known as a Dylan Mad
Bruce who acts as if he's 100 fact based
has been exposed the video he used as
Source against Andrew Tate was
deceptively edited to push a narrative
push in there what's my narrative what's
my name that he's self snitched that he
did this
I mean there's nothing I said in my
video that wasn't true it's a silly hat
and if you don't believe I'm a lawyer
look go to
www.riverslawyers.com and call me up my
telephone number is
612-339-3939 call me up you can find out
that I'm a real lawyer old people making
content is just like it's own right now
so cringy should we call him be like hey
are you actually a lawyer if you don't
believe I'm a lawyer you can look it up
here it's like bro well let's see what
he has to say maybe he's of any interest
or Wheels it's just like it's such
fourth grade stuff though if you don't
believe my dad's in the NBA you can look
it up I know I know it is funny
I try real cases and I kick some real
ass
Dylan anyway I'm not gonna ask too much
we're gonna we're gonna react I haven't
seen it he's like Pierce Morgan
sometimes I think is effective sometimes
I think he's a tool but it doesn't
matter what I think let's hear what his
lawyer had to say
father Tristan are being held as part of
your investigation into rape and human
trafficking or speaking outside cool
Andrew Taylor he's done nothing wrong
free my boy
now remember as he's walking out of
there that's like December 29th or
something like that a few days later
guess what his Bugatti his begotten is
begone
this guy is so I'm innocent
he doesn't even charge that person
[Music]
well if I can still with me plus joining
me now is the lawyer forward Tafe
Brothers Tina Landing who is in Romania
well welcome to uh the violent
misogynist hire a woman to represent
them who was that other but we saw a
different lawyer that was representing
the Romanian dude I think they got rid
of them I mean if you're still in jail
you have multiple lawyers I mean there's
Criminal lawyers there's business
lawyers probably so but I mean if I'm
still in jail for doing nothing wrong
I'm hiring someone else I shave his head
he goes I mean a woman is definitely
better Optics he's the new Andrew yeah
now Tina Glennon is uh you know she got
her chops as it were representing Mike
Tyson and uh uh Chris Brown we know how
those came out let's see what she has to
say we appreciate you joining me where
are we with this case it seems like
every now and again this pops up back on
television with the being reminded for
further time how long she was pretty
back in the day for the show before a
charging decision hey pissed what color
is your Bugatti under Romanian law they
have up to 180 days which is in 30-day
increments so every time there's a 30
day Vision order they're allowed to
renew their requests and have it
suspended for an additional 30 days but
all right that's something I didn't know
so every 30 days they get you know it's
for up to 180 days so six months and but
they but it's got to be reviewed every
30 days 60 to 180 days okay
you've taken on this case Andrew Tay has
been repeatedly uh developed and she was
added to his team and I told you I told
you that he was going to either add or
change lawyers in his innocence as he's
being led in and out of of these cool
hearings and so on
do you believe them do you believe that
he and his brother are innocent
at this point Pierce they've had this
investigation going since April we're
now February and there are not even
charges filed against them so this is a
huge Injustice the way we see it they
should not be detained at this point we
think it's now crossed over to the point
where it's violating international human
rights law
so she actually has a point there they
haven't been detained since April so the
the investigation itself can go on for
whatever length but they've been
detained for almost 60 days now right
and so
remember when I tell you in our system
you know
within 36 hours you have to see a judge
36 to 48 Hours depending upon where you
are and so and you're entitled to bail
you're entitled to know what you're
accused of yeah but here in the states
it's it's not exactly awesome either so
you get to see a judge but this court
systems are so backed up that you could
you could sit and rot in jail for months
or years before your trial date is is
set and it's really sucks because if say
you know you're you're saying that
you're not guilty and what if you really
aren't guilty and you're rotting in jail
without bail or because you couldn't
afford to post bail if bail was an
option then do you get your money back
for bail if you were innocent I believe
you do should yeah but still imagine if
you're if you can't afford bail even if
it's five or ten Grand and you just you
you can't it's not there some it's
that's that's a lot of people and you
you're just rotting in jail and the
court system is backed up and you could
sit there for six months and your whole
life falls apart in the meantime you
lose your home you lose your you could
lose your family you obviously any job
or income you had is out the window I
mean it's it's really crazy even here in
the states these guys have unlimited
resources or you know tremendous
resources so them sitting in jail sucks
but their their lives are going to be
okay at the end of this hold up let me
see something but but for a Romanian who
you know who who they can detain you
while they're collecting evidence what
the hell is that how is that even
possible how does a regular Average Joe
Romanian survive your whole life is
ruined yeah one second I I kind of agree
with her on this because the deprivation
of of your Liberty pre-trial is the most
severe form of punishment a state can
impose and that's what they've done in
this case and they've had a very lengthy
investigation with the government's
resources they've been uh analyzing and
look looking at all of their devices
since April When They seized everything
now it would be a real travesty of
Justice I mean let's let's say for the
sake of argument that they don't find
anything and that he's never charged
with a crime he'll be bigger than ever
bigger than ever because he will be this
martyr against the Matrix right The
Matrix so the Matrix is out to get
everybody
and this guy is such a clown I'm sorry
but like how do you not see that there's
people that have ultimate control over
stuff and then a corrupt country that
there's people that say Okay I want Tate
in jail and he's in jail yeah like what
what is it what is he acting like the
Matrix is so crazy for oh people don't
actually run the world because he's so
in it that he can't see it
right the Matrix so the Matrix is out to
get everybody he bought that tie in The
Matrix and here we are February in
charge of steak is real juicy buddy
there's absolutely no evidence that's
been presented
and
part of that's not true there's some
evidence that's been presented to the
court
why that's our position
I mean how are your clients at the
moment how is Andrew Tate dealing with
incarceration I mean I interviewed him
just before Christmas we had a long
wide-ranged interview and once again I
was struck by the phenomenal
following that he has online
particularly with young men you know you
we know you guys are following and
you're watching me too not all of you
but but uh here's the thing I don't
really have it out for Andrew Tate I
think he's a little tasteless you know
he could be a little more
I don't know a little less bravado and
I'm not jealous of him I mean I like who
I am but I also don't like Injustice so
even if he's guilty of everything he
said if they can't prove it they
shouldn't he shouldn't be
dealing with it
um how is he faring right now given at
the moment he's in his limbo land of no
charging but being held uh in
incarceration
the brothers are both very strong
they're resilient and they're holding up
but obviously the conditions are not
good they're in a Romanian jail cell and
they've been detained for a very lengthy
period at this point they have limited
access to their attorneys um it's it's
not a good condition for them
please finish
I was just gonna I was gonna say to your
second point
their controversial public figures but
that's not a crime at this point this is
on the news provided any proof that
they've committed any crimes nor have
they even been charged so I would ask
that people presume them innocent as
they are
and that's a good point that's a fair
point you're always innocent until
proven guilty
and I really and I don't like the fact
they've been held without charging for
60 days
I mean that that's a little
disconcerting
a little they feel that they are being
tried in the court of public opinion I
think I think the public where's BLM
coming out to help a fellow black
brother stuck in jail he's their brother
no divided as you know I think they have
a big follow-up at the end of the day
yesterday there's a lot of information
in the public I think there's a lot of
false allegations in the public
I think some evidence has now been put
forth again I don't want to comment too
much on the facts of the case since
there is an ongoing criminal
investigation however I think there has
been evidence put out
um videos and other statements for the
public to see what the uh supposed state
of the evidence action now actually I
kind of like the way she's presenting
this she's presentable she doesn't come
off as boisterous and she comes off as
very factual and knowledgeable and and a
strident advocate for her client so this
is an example of a really good lawyer
it's a continued tweet is he doing that
himself you know what I'd really like
Sonny I really like to find a video
where there's somebody talking
intelligently about Romanian criminal
law we learned we learned one thing here
about how that you can you know the 180
and then every 30 days every 30 the
30-day increments of detention but
that's all we've really learned in all
the videos we've watched nobody has
anything intelligent to say it's all
nonsense I would like to would like I
mean I guess that could be us we could
do some research but I am not I I can't
read Romanian he blundered going back
there after converting to Islam and then
and then going should have just stayed
in Dubai you'd be chilling yeah
he said he was staying in Dubai for the
winter right yeah but I think they just
wanted to go back for like a couple
weeks just like switches probably yeah
you go you got I get it you go to your
main house for the holidays that's what
everybody does
ah yeah well again he doesn't have
access so he's not doing anything
directly and what's being put out is is
on his accounts and I'm not gonna speak
as to you know the source of of the
she's not going to speak to the source
you know why she's not gonna because
anything that's out there can be used
against him so if she attributes those
words to Andrew Tate well
they can use it against it it was kind
of cute I was talking to Grandma and she
said that she saw some things from
Andrew Tate and I was telling her you
know that I get emails from his email
list so I just see what he has to say
and she's like oh how oh so he's able to
just keep sending emails and tweets and
stuff and I was like oh great I was like
well no he's got a whole team trust me
he's got a team of copywriters and
people that deal with all his social
media he's not doing it I wonder if he's
like writing anything down for them to
tweet probably some of it I mean maybe
he's able to do some written
communication some letters and things I
imagine there's some communication that
he's able or occasional x amount of
visitors that he's allowed so yeah
there's some of it but these people also
know who's brain his brand and his mind
so well that but it was kind of cute out
but I think again as of now he's not
charged with anything and uh he's free
to comment know that They seized uh
nearly three and a half million pounds
in cash 11 luxury sports cars guns and
other weapons
actually they were taking another five
vehicles like I think they've
15 or 16 vehicles and almost 4 million
uh in cash
he'll never see any of that again why
why why what justifies taking his cars
in cash what does that have to do with
anything if there was a good explanation
I would love it that's what I want to
hear I'm with you and you're so [__]
there is some Romanian cop's wife with a
lot of new diamonds right now so when
the Tates were leaving they yelled out
or Tristan yelled he's like they're
doing this to take my money would it
really be that simple like it's not even
like the Matrix like people sending them
to take him but it's really just the
government wants to take his cars and
his money would they do all of that for
10 20 million dollars worth of stuff his
Bugatti's not detained either Bozo
that's in Dubai are they in themselves
acts of law breaking just the possession
of any of these things so on that note
if
I'm running a criminal organization
and I buy a Rolls-Royce
and I buy it with the proceeds from that
criminal organization
that Rolls-Royce is now
product of veal gotten canes so you can
so that can go bye-bye yeah but wouldn't
that be after you prove that that's
where it's from why would you take it in
the meantime oh we're just going to hold
this for you that means they I mean they
could legit do that to anybody then yeah
that doesn't like when you're getting an
IRS audit they can just come and before
they've charged you with any crime just
take everything just in case you did
something wrong what is that in other
words forfeitable again this is the most
severe form of punishment I don't think
it's Justified under these circumstances
where the prosecution doesn't set forth
enough evidence to charge them and yet
they are detained uh and it's one of the
dangers in making statements like this
is that
you can wind up eating your words
so these are not that bad of words to
eat though oh there's not enough
evidence for them to do this and then
the evidence shows up oh okay all right
thank you for presenting evidence at
least like that's not her eat her words
this guy's a marshmallow so you know you
know what this guy looks like I don't
know I'm not trying to be rude
charged him by now these are not easy
charges to present
what are you doing oh no you know what
I'm looking for oh I know no um
this dude this dude
this is what the guy looks like I'm
sorry but come on what's his name in
real life um I forget his name my Droopy
Dog or something yeah oh come on don't
that's mean no I don't like that that's
mean they look alike
they're complicated but you do accept of
course that if the women who that's a
good comparison to the investigation if
they're telling the truth these are very
serious allegations against your clients
which could lead to charging and if I
led to charging could lead potentially
to Long prison sentences if found guilty
certainly the the crimes that issue are
very serious crimes and I think Pierce
actually it was on your show when you
interviewed Tate several months ago he
made very strong statements about his
position on rape and he condemned rape
he may have condemned rape but he said
in his own videos I mean he's made
different statements at other times that
totally contradict these this very
public thing that he said give me one
give me one when has he ever said it's
okay to rape a woman I'm not saying he
never said it I'm saying I've never seen
him say it and I all I've seen is people
saying that he said it I got my PhD and
he didn't say that stuff it was all good
advice he but do you know what I'm
saying it's I've only seen people say he
said rape women that's all I've seen
I've never seen him say it I've never
honestly like one of the first people to
give like good advice on women like
genuinely good advice that like you're a
gentleman you do everything right and in
the process you still get girls not in a
creepy way at all either he's like the
first person that I've listened to his
girl advice and I've been like this is
fire not like the typical Matrix stuff
where it's like it's okay to cry in
front of your girl it's okay to be weak
and emotional that's lies that's lies it
is lies it's such every time a man is
too emotional I'm like no it's [__] I I
look back at the last girl that I talked
to before I started listening to Tate
and like in the moment I was like oh
[__] this girl it was like her fault
that it didn't work out and then looking
back it's like that was totally my fault
why were you emotional yeah I was just I
was like a [__] about it so like
there's there's a I don't know a few
different things so like we went out to
dinner once with her her friend and my
friend and when it came time to pay it
was like you know 400 bill and I paid
but like I wasn't a g about it like I
should have just paid him and like it's
nothing don't worry about it but I was
like I was I didn't know how the pay was
going to work when the bill came I
didn't know if they're gonna offer to
split because it was like four people
and it was a nice place you know what I
mean right and um I don't know I was
just I wasn't as like much of a g about
it like I wasn't just like here don't
worry about it you know what I mean
right it's like oh it's 300 [__] like I
was like that and then another time I
[__] cried in front of her once too
which was just so stupid that'll ruin it
every time and then right after that
that was like I think the last time I
ever saw her funny enough how that works
you know what it's okay we gotta have
some mistakes yeah
shares by it like I you you live and you
learn and I appreciate you you know like
sharing that because everybody that's
feeling that like no everyone's gone
like you got to be you know I yeah I've
done the same thing like you know like
calling a guy and like no but I feel
like it's better to be open on the
camera you're not coming over I'm not
perfect like you got to be open on
camera not act like I've done everything
right there's some other [__] that I did
wrong and like looking back yes I would
FaceTime her every night no need for
that I'm a busy guy [__] off you don't
need to FaceTime your girl every night
that's ridiculous
um she's out going to frat parties and
[__] and I didn't like set any
boundaries like next girl I'm talking to
you're not going to [__] frat parties
yeah no it's just not happening
especially if I'm thinking about taking
you more seriously you're a potential
mother stock you are being tested to
onboard the sunny train and work with me
as I ride through the Matrix and lead us
to Greatness if you want to be out in
the back going to frat parties you can
get off the [__] train that's how
it's gonna work go in the cargo car I
mean just so much coming into the dining
car no but the advice they give is just
genuinely amazing stuff and I haven't
seen anything that's been remotely
creepy if anything girls like love how
much of a gentleman I am and then when I
tell them I'm like oh guess who guess
where I got that from they totally
contradict these this very public thing
that he said he said it was disgusting
it was I'm pretty sure the word he used
and he said he thought that somebody who
does that deserves the death penalty so
there's no question that
you know I remember seeing this guy was
convicted and he said I didn't do this
and the judge said well
you didn't do this but who do you the
person who did do this what what do you
think that person should get
and he looked at the church well you
should get uh life in prison or whatever
he said and the judge gave him exactly
what he said so when you say that kind
of thing you can eat your own words oh
my God bro this guy's such a fruit he
didn't rape any women bro it's so funny
I I can't with this [__] man I I
don't even know where this guy gets his
information from his teenage daughter
like where is this guy getting it truly
I I couldn't tell you I couldn't tell
you his daughter it's so sad because
they say everyone's raping women
everyone's a racist and it diminishes
what those things actually mean so much
that now when you call people it doesn't
mean anything yeah I I everyone's a
rapist like literally everyone that gets
some clout is a rapist or a racist if
there's some reason for someone not to
like them like oh we're all just racist
and rapists at the top that's just how
it works bozos so I it has always been
extremely difficult for women to come
forward about rape because the thought
of standing in front of a room of uh you
know in a court or a policeman then a
hospital team of doctors and nurses then
a courtroom and the thought of standing
in front of all of those people and
having to talk about the most horrible
thing you've ever been through the most
personal violating thing you've ever
been through is extremely difficult for
a woman to take that step and say I'm
going to do this now for a woman to do
it I bet I think they're making it even
harder because it went so because of
what you're saying it went so far where
they made it seem like you know rape is
just overused and nobody you know nobody
really takes these accusations even
seriously anymore with this metoo
movement they ruined it yes and so now
for a woman to come forward she now has
to face that [__] also of oh is this
just another me too libtard idiot
complaining or is this a real problem so
it was hard enough and they're just
making it harder for women everything's
getting harder for women sports the
other thing tastes supposedly in trouble
for for lover boy method which isn't
even rape that's getting girls to fall
in love with you and then using them for
work so where is rape coming into the
equation now because that's not even a
part of it lover boy method yeah that
never happened look at look at what do
you remember Goodfellas when Henry Hill
had his girl on the side and his wife
and he made them both fall in love with
him and then help him run his Coke ring
and all his crimes was that loverboying
well no the funniest
criminal [__] the funniest part about
lover boy to me is if a girl was using a
guy for something she wanted nothing
would happen yeah look at cardi B she's
a superstar everybody talks about she's
a queen she's this she's so awesome she
drugged men and robbed that and she
actually admitted and admits it and
talks about it like it's a joke yeah
that's crazy it's it's such a clown
world that those people can walk free
and he's detained for 60 days now with
no proof we're partnering up with a Navy
SEAL friend of ours Tom Shea host a 21
day virtual event that you guys can join
with us Tom is gonna teach you how to
listen to your mind in a new way and how
to control it so that you can have the
discipline you need to build the life
you want so I've seen this process done
for 30 years when you make it through
you will be a different human being the
process is simple but not easy because
of the war that's inside of us that few
people have been taught to fight
overcoming your excuses so if you're
interested becoming a reformed human an
absolute animal go to tomshay.com and
use funny fast 50 for 50 off of this
program you will not regret it you will
be a changed person at the end of it do
not miss this these are serious charges
and this clown even in his own words
they're very serious charges there just
isn't any evidence that they committed
these crimes but you know we've also had
all right that's not true there's you
got his own admission and then you have
these statements from these women
that's going to be questioned you know
that this is this man is a lawyer and he
is unprepared he's making General
statements without any facts he keeps
saying things like Oh by his own
admission and then he does no and that's
it and then he just leaves it there
you're a lawyer I would never hire this
lawyer if this is how he makes an
article you know when I'll hire this
lawyer if I need to go if I need to go
to jail it's examined you're gonna have
other women I guarantee you he's gonna
have women supporters that are going to
come and testify on his behalf we're
being various tapes of surfaced in part
of media investigations in the last few
weeks including Andrew Tate talking
about rape to a woman in a pretty
unsavory manner so what would
first of all he said tapes can I just
tell you something there's no [__]
tape anymore they're recordings and
these were uh WhatsApp recordings
there's no tape anymore nobody uses tape
do I use tape do you use tape no and
people call talk about tape recordings
we saw stop we saw that in the vice in
the vice video we did when we reacted to
the vice documentary where the girl said
something on the WhatsApp and then he
left a message like I'm sorry to hear a
new bitching but they were in a
six-month relationship and they gave no
time stamps on those audios to see if
that was part of the same conversation
like hey you raped me and hey I'm sick
of hearing you [__] well they also
didn't show her response and like I said
so that could have been from any point
in their relationship which is what
happens in a relationship that's not
going well when people are fighting I am
tired of hearing your [__] you know cut
it out yeah so it we don't know that
that comment was related to that comment
because again there was no time stamp
and there was no I mean if that is the
case show us but nobody has so I'll
edited for their narrative
people mine
first of all I think oh I remember the
other thing I did wrong with the girl I
didn't stay mysterious with my
occupation Gotta Stay kind of cool with
how you make your money I was explaining
nfts to the girl never want to do that
girls shouldn't be hearing about
non-fungible tokens no wives want to
hear about what you do or like fiances
like once they get past that and they're
already they're on your team and that in
you well they're spending enough time
with you they're gonna find out
eventually right but initially you got
to play cool it's just like you got to
think about it from the woman mind you
know they don't want to know exactly
what you do and want a sense of mystery
because then they fill that in their
head to the coolest thing possible it's
true it's true and actually I I've even
to some at some points like controlled
that for my own mistake because I was
dating this homicide detective once and
he had some cool stories and so I'd get
a few stories out of them and then
there'd be like one that I would be like
you know what that sounds like really
horrible don't tell me I don't want to
know and then he would catch on and he'd
be like yeah it's too terrible for me to
even I don't even want that in your head
and I'd be like good job good like
inside it'd be like good job remain
mysterious like and it you're absolutely
right but I was I was a grown woman so I
knew enough to like make sure that I
didn't lose interest yeah and stop him
before he told me too much you're
absolutely right a little mystery is
good I'm telling you his advice and not
dry and [__] and you know mystery of
you lying where you're going just I like
knowing that you got some badass [__]
going on that I don't know about it's
cool city of anything that is presented
through the media as opposed to turned
over
authenticity of it so first attack that
it's not the real message I've seen so
many um in cells talk about this is you
know this is doctored it's I you know
we've analyzed the voice recording and
it's just not accurate
come on or to talk to people's desires
or fetishes but certainly somebody could
easily set someone up by saying they
like they have certain fantasies they
want
certain things done to them or said to
them and so there's a lot that goes into
you can't she's being effective advocate
here you hear the little he has a little
dog you can hear of course he has to bat
this away I mean that's her position
right so of course she's going to bat
this away and I think she's doing a
fantastic job actually we have to give
your mind also the judge's reasoning
he's a nice guy
they viewed the particular dangerousness
of a defendants and their capacity to
identify victims with increased
vulnerability in such a better life
opportunity at the moment there have
been no charges against your clients and
until or if that point arrives we're in
a world of allegation not actual charges
correct and right now exactly there's a
presumption of innocence
two and that every accused has and that
attaches from the time you're even
charged and here we're not even there
they haven't even charged them with
crimes so any sort of comments as to the
their alleged dangerousness there's no
and I do have a problem with them you
know being held as long as they've been
held without it without charges and I
can't believe they can be held up to 180
days
that does have an unsavory feel to it
unsavory what is the average Joe in
Romania do they need to be presumed
innocent and that's that hasn't happened
in this case there's really a lack of
evidence and they are being detained
unlawfully at this point well that's not
true they aren't being detained lawfully
but the law is [__] yeah maybe
immorally but but by an international
standard that's probably what she's
talking about
and I and I I do agree with her I mean
you I don't care if it's entertained or
I don't care if it's Charles Manson I
don't care if it's Steve Shake is you
cannot be held you know without charging
like this I mean it's just not the way
the Western World does it it's the way
maybe oh your head's cut off the camera
yeah so anyway so this is our reaction
to Andrew Tate's lawyer talking to
Pierce Morgan and we'll see you next
time here on criminal lawyer reacts
remember remember I am a real lawyer
Dylan yeah we know buddy thank you thank
you for the reminder I'm a real lawyer I
don't just play one on YouTube yeah all
right Bud all right thank you guys so
much for watching make sure to like
subscribe follow me on Instagram at
sunnyfast join my Discord I have a free
preview inside of how I've generated
over five million dollars totally free
you can go inside check it out ask us
any questions you want and I'll see you
later
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings